the work is mysterious and important
and we deal with the uncertainty it
brings us in the way that keir would
have wanted
together
as a family hey guys pete here it's time
to talk about my favorite thing which
right now is severance on apple tv plus
episode 4 just came out and ended with a
massive cliffhanger and we also found
out that i was wrong about the one from
last week sort of the fourth episode
takes its name from ricken's book the
you you are it's a spiritual biography
of you and this episode is another fine
installment that asked what if the u-u-r
isn't a kind and caring person at least
not to the other you you are which
happens to be fairly important in this
context of bifurcated realities let's
look at what's going on in mdr down in
that crazy basement of lumen industries
beyond what is turning out to be one
hell of an on-screen romance i'll be
recapping everything that happened and
talk about what i think it all might
mean right after a quick spoiler warning
if you haven't watched severance season
1 episode 4 yet then this video won't be
for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it
okay so i may have been a little
premature last week when i said the
break room seemed more annoying than
something you would find horrifying
episode four opens with heli continuing
to read the compunction statement and
from the looks of things she's been
there for a while milchak looks at a
printout before telling her he's afraid
she still doesn't mean it it is time for
her to go home but he assures her
they'll try again in the morning you see
her leave and since we haven't seen
things from the perspective of her audi
since the first episode she immediately
returns the next day you learn that she
has already read the statement 259 times
and when she starts again you start to
hear a voice in the background she kind
of breaks down saying that she is really
sorry she really is and he looks at this
and says hey you're paraphrasing and has
her start over you'll learn later that
she had to do this 1072
times and when she brought up the angry
mumbly voice she heard dylan thinks
she's talking about the crying baby he
apparently hears and he gives her the
advice that the trick is to think about
something you're really sorry about
there's an indication that helly's
experience might be on the brutal end of
the spectrum but no one really seems
surprised which means the break room is
actually no joke not everything is so
bad though because bert shows up in mdr
in the flesh with pre-release handbook
totes this is the first time we've seen
someone in their office from a different
department and it's a great little back
and forth between irv and bert of course
dylan isn't so happy to see him and he
grabs a stapler and gets aggressive when
asked how he found it he says his
predecessor visited when they used to do
summits so i don't know what that's all
about but when dylan brought up the idea
of them disemboweling people again kind
of picking up with what he was talking
about in the previous episode i got to
thinking that these ideas had to come
from somewhere dylan is quirky he has
some crazy ideas about what might be
going on outside the building but when
he talks about this history with o and d
it sounds like that's coming from an
actual source either way as he's leaving
burt offers a tour of ond if they ever
want and he leaves a map it feels like
irv takes him up on this offer
immediately i'm not sure if there's
supposed to be the sense of some time
passing there but he does it citing
keir's original vision of everyone
working together he follows the very
nondescript map and he makes it to ond
where he's greeted by felicia he gets a
look around and confesses to bert that
he cried when they put up the painting
the youthful convalescence of care
saying he never thought he would see the
handbook passage depicted visually bert
shows him the actual painting which they
have stored in a drawer and as they
recite a passage about it together they
make a move and they touch hands and
then irv sort of freaks out and leaves
on the way back he passes the conference
room where milchik was reading ricken's
book remember he left it there when the
alarms went off and he had to go help
mark with helly
she had seen him looking at petey's map
and while he's in the kitchen she goes
into his drawer and takes it this leads
to a heated discussion about the rules
and ultimately mark shreds the map to
prove that he doesn't care about it that
does seem to be in contrast with the
fact that we had seen him looking at it
kind of obsessively up until that point
but it's done and irv comes in to tell
him about the emergency at the same time
it's just raining contraband today so
ricken's book is there it's definitely
not supposed to be it has the
inscription to mark inside and it's
hilarious that he doesn't know what this
is or who this person is that wrote it
irv thinks it might be a loyalty test he
brings up something that has to do with
spicy candy dylan thinks it's booty and
mark just says that he'll be turning it
into mill check while they're out of the
office hely discovers the paper cutter
which she takes into mrs koble's office
and threatens to cut off her fingers
with it if she won't give her a camera
to make a resignation plea to her audi
they do give in and allow her to make
the video and you see her getting ready
to leave through the elevator on her way
out she tells mark i guess this is the
part where i should tell you to go to
hell but you're already here and tells
mailchick she was never sorry just to
get one more in before she goes again
you see this situation where the door
closes and she leaves and then returns
holding a different video in the same
hand that her audi made for her in that
she hears that her audi understands that
she's unhappy with the life she's been
given but she doesn't care the audi says
that she's a person and the innie is not
she makes the decisions and if the innie
ever does anything to her fingers know
that she'll keep her alive long enough
to horribly regret that her resignation
request is denied and that is
devastating for several reasons which
we'll come back to
there were two parts to last week's
cliffhanger one of those was the phone
that pd left behind at mark's house audi
mark picked that up at the beginning of
the episode and saw that all the calls
in the log are from a blocked number for
the time being he just puts it in a box
and leaves it the second part was what
happened to petey and at home markets a
notification from the kier chronicle and
learns that pd did in fact die and the
headline reads that it happened after he
collapsed from an unknown ailment if you
zoom in and read the text under the
photo it reads while the severance
procedure remains statistically very
safe its reversal can be fatal after
reading this he looks at his basement
door and we see the box where he hid the
phone and can hear that it's ringing
inside after the news gets out grayner
comes to kobel's office to ask if she's
heard from the board yet she hasn't and
he thinks that they'll understand that
this wasn't their fault she brings up
reintegration which he reminds her the
board has never acknowledged and that
kind of makes you think that this has
happened before but there's no way to
tell she wants to get her hands on his
chip and he tells her the body will be
destroyed by cremation after the funeral
at her desk she says the nine core
principles out loud vision verve wit
cheer humility benevolence nimbleness
probity and wiles she says wiles twice
while she looks at an old black and
white portrait of someone in a small
frame that she keeps on her desk and i
found that one kind of surprising and i
had to go look it up to make sure and it
turns out it's mentioned on the fake
linkedin profile the tv show made mark
decides to go to petey's funeral and is
surprised when he runs into mrs selvig
there he says he's there because the
news reports that he worked at lumen so
he thought he might know the guy and she
makes up a story about him visiting her
shop he meets petey's ex-wife and his
daughter and she asks him if he ever
thought the best way to deal with a
messed up situation in your life isn't
just to shut your brain off half the
time this made me wonder what drove
petey to want to do the procedure in the
first place and i wonder if we'll see
this character again while they're
watching a video of her performing enter
sandman with her father in their garage
mrs selby goes and removes the lumen
chip from his head i mean she gets right
in there with a drill and just takes it
out it is a closed casket so no one
notices immediately and mark is affected
by watching the video so he decides to
leave and she uses that as her chance to
get out of there leaving with him when
they get back instead of going into his
house he drives in his car to the spot
where his wife's accident happened and
we see him step over the guardrail and
touch the tree as tears stream down his
face
the next day at the office harmony shows
petey's chip to miltcheck who takes it
up to diagnostics for her then miss
casey arrives and she tells her that she
wants to run a special wellness session
for mark s irv goes looking for bird
again they talk in front of the water
fountain and bert apologizes for
touching his hand but irv quickly tells
them it isn't necessary the way they
share this sort of religious devotion to
the company makes all of their
interactions so much fun to watch and at
the end of this one he tells him he
doesn't just speak to us through the
handbook and the paintings he finds
other ways you learn that mark did not
turn over ricken's book to milk check
and now that the map has been shredded
he spends his alone time in the bathroom
reading that in the chapter he's looking
at ricken is talking about living abroad
as a beggar relying on the charity of
strangers it ends with the idea that
your job needs you not the other way
around the last sequence is set up as a
kind of montage heli says goodbye to
dylan and when she walks out you see
that she's carrying an extension cord
and then she also grabs the trash can in
the hallway as she walks past that mark
is waiting for his wellness session and
dylan takes the opportunity to look in
his desk where he finds the you you are
and he starts to read it too his reading
of the acrostic poem destiny continues
through the end of the episode in the
session miss casey lights mark's wife's
candle and she gives him some clay to
sculpt out how he's feeling and as he
gets started you see that harmony is
watching the session in her office irv
decides to turn back to ond before he
goes back to mdr when he doesn't see
anyone he hears a noise coming from a
door in the back of their space when he
looks inside he finds a massive room
with several additional employees
working with burt and felicia mark
starts to sculpt the tree where his
wife's crash happened and as harmony's
looking at that it makes you wonder if
this is concerning because should his
annie know anything about that is this
confirming what petey said about him
bringing that with him heli has made it
to the elevator and made a noose out of
the extension cord you see that irv
looks somewhat disoriented as he's
walking back from o and d and then you
see heli kick out the garbage can below
her as the episode ends last week i was
wrong about petey being dead but i'm
gonna go there again because this never
really felt like an ending for hely i
don't think you would play it as a
cliffhanger if that was the case if she
was going to die from this i believe
they would have had that happen before
the credits came up petey felt like he
performed his role in the story could
you say the same for hely at this point
i still think she's our window into what
it's like for people when they first
experienced this her reaction is more
extreme than summer even most probably
but my guess is that no one just wakes
up and thinks okay this sounds great
show me how to take care of these scary
numbers i think until you adjust you
probably just would kind of want to
escape heli having to face the reality
that her audi doesn't care how bad it is
for her at work is kind of what makes
this story more interesting than one
where you just lose all your memories
they still are adult human beings that
know things their experiential realities
just begin when they wake up on the
table their experiences are that limited
when they only have access to their any
memories you kind of see this when she
was about to hang herself and she thinks
about that short conversation with mark
it was a nice exchange that showed both
characters in a good light that made you
feel bad that she was about to die but
it almost felt like this was her
greatest memory from her short existence
that highlights everything horrible
about finding out the other version of
you doesn't have your back where can she
even go from here the special wellness
session is also pretty interesting the
candle is a very specific inclusion
that's hard to explain in a way that
doesn't involve her testing if he can
experience his audi's memories could she
really be trying to do something that
would be comforting for him sure but
this is the same person who took a drill
to petey's skull to find out what was
going on with his chip her behavior here
seems to back up my thoughts from last
week's video that it's important for
them to keep anything negative from
getting out everything they do is set up
to indoctrinate the severed employees
and you get the idea that it's working
through the constant references to the
handbook there's a reservoir of great
lines to draw from there and i like how
erv who never tires of going there chose
to overlook my favorite one from this
episode render not my creation in
miniature irv bert's map is a clear
violation i guess everyone bends the
rules when it suits them speaking of
bert i'm not sure what to make of the
rest of o and d because he kept it a
secret i think it might come off as
being more nefarious than it actually is
in mdr they don't even know what they do
the work is mysterious and important and
they deal with it as kier intended
together as a family i know in one of
the promo videos the show's creators
said they try to keep the departments
away from each other so things are
naturally mysterious through dylan and
felicia we see that it's also somewhat
tribal i don't think we can say that
what's going on here is that much
different than what we see in mdr but
we'll have to wait to find out petey was
convinced that some people never get to
leave but i didn't get that vibe here
there are so many interesting details
just hanging out there i can't wait to
see how some of this stuff like the dirt
under herbs fingernails comes back up i
love the idea of their baby brains being
infected by ricken's book imagine if the
only thing you've really read is the
handbook how profound this might
actually seem everything still seems to
be firing on all cylinders i know that
there was a director change in this
episode
and the vision still seemed consistent
with the pacing it almost seems as if
they ratchet things up as the episode
progresses and the idea of a big
cliffhanger at the end of every episode
could be tiring but these all seem to be
set up pretty well the prospect of this
leading to something even bigger is
pretty exciting i thought this was
another great episode and there's so
much stuff i could go on forever but
this is probably a good place to stop
let me know in the comments what you
thought about this cliffhanger the
terrible ordeal that helies audi is
putting her through what are they gonna
find out when they look at petey's chip
and when is mark gonna answer that
telephone please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon